love his blind is back [ __ ] i love
that i love that i thought
i love that get out of here jessica and
you are not going to believe some of the
absolute catches on this
season love is blind sees 10 men and 10
women on a quest for love well i see how
long it'll take before i gouge my eyes
out but fear not i have traversed the
vast tropical rivers of chicago and have
returned with some of the best moments
from the season so sit back grab your
golden wine glasses so we actually don't
know how much the contestants have been
drinking because someone's gotta justify
why nick and vanessa lachey get their
million dollar checks for three minutes
of screen time our journey begins in the
pods inhibitor pods sleep deprivation
pots pea plants all you said was the
people know the love pods where our
contestants struggle to navigate red
flag mountain i have a huge instagram
following okay red flag you remind me so
much of my mother big red flag if we
were to be at a music festival
do you like being on a guy's shoulders
but um will i have trouble picking you
up
oh boy another red flag i'm also a house
dj kill me
right now but before we begin we have to
let nick remind us how successful this
dating method is you know and this
experiment is now a proven approach to
finding love meanwhile i don't deal with
[ __ ] like you
oh i'm a [ __ ] now [ __ ] you [ __ ] watch
my ass to the next dick ah proven
approach the pod phase takes place over
the course of 10 days that's 10 days to
establish a connection find the love of
your life and propose those who do not
are immediately sent home and forced to
live out the rest of their lives
depressed and alone but let's take a
moment to meet our contestants who will
be taking things to the next level first
there's jared jared nice to meet you yes
not like the subway guy it tastes
awesome too ianna so it's like if i'm
not like really dressed up sometimes i
can look like a 13 year old boy
salvador
[Music]
malory who loves to come into the pod's
double fisting shane the living
embodiment of gary busey natalie if he
looks like
i don't know like an ogre it wouldn't
impact shake i love buying clothes for
girls
yeah what's your size deep dee she's
just really sweet i have nothing bad to
say about her nick so i've been making
my own toothpaste
bear with me danielle my biggest
downfall is the way that i kind of
think about things bruh kyle what do you
do i love to punch drywall and the piece
to resistance shayna who immediately
after agreeing to get engaged has to
take a shot and has a meltdown within a
few meetings relationships form along
with some spicy love triangles shane
ends up forming a connection with both
natalie and shayna with natalie
something more emotional and with shayna
well what are you wearing over there
what are you wearing what's going on why
are you holding a little bed oh you are
so [ __ ] hot and things explode for
shane when he's caught playing both
women even getting into one pod thinking
it was shayna on the other side when in
fact it was natalie hi who am i talking
to you i don't know take a guess no oh
say no there you go
why oh that's what i was hoping for
what are you wearing over there he's the
type of guy who cheat on a girl and
still find a way to blame her for it
he'll end up choosing natalie going into
phase two but we'll get to that in a bit
shake shake shake sonora you sound like
beetlejuice this guy is a piece of work
what's up my strong suit
no one cares a veterinarian with a
penchant for asses who only dates fit
blonde white women
as soon as i see her it's gonna be two
hands
boom that booty is not safe
oh my god oh my god
hi
booty look at that booty oh just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit this
is just 20 minutes after he said this
i've come a long way getting past
superficial motivations for things he'll
end up proposing to deepti and if you
really want to feel embarrassed or
someone else jarrod gets rejected by his
number one choice mallory and then
proposes to his second choice and ianna
knows she's number two
she'll have to decide whether she wants
to go home alone or explore the
possibilities of an engagement knowing
she wasn't the number one pick sal has
found a way to mallory's heart by
playing the ukulele he just better watch
out when this guy starts hitting on his
girl
[Music]
nick and danielle get hitched but most
of their problems will occur over the
next few weeks but it's kyle and shayna
who have the rockiest of starts things
begin well and the two develop a strong
emotional connection however things hit
a huge roadblock when shayna finds out
that kyle's an atheist i want to know
why you're an atheist
i just
believe science
god is science bruh but kyle still wants
to propose his mom was religious and she
made him the happiest boy in the world
he still has his doubts though am i
gonna throw away an amazing woman
because we disagree on a religion yes
kyle she believes that when you die if
you're a non-believer you'll spend an
eternity in hellfire which is slightly
better than chicago where he's from i'm
kidding i'm kidding i used to live there
the couples have their big reveals and
all in all six make it to the honeymoon
phase an all-expense trip to mexico
where the only thing more empty than the
resort is my heart stephanie please take
me back these couples include shane and
natalie jared and ianna sal and mal nick
and danielle shake and deepti and kyle
and shayna this is where our couples get
to explore their relationships and see
if their emotional connections from the
ponds can transfer to the physical but
as our couples navigate love some
important decisions have to be made i
want to wait until we're married to like
actually have sex um i would think it
was like the first night that we would
spend the night in separate rooms
i don't know if i'm feeling the type of
like body connection that i wanted to
feel probably notice i like a late night
snack
once in a while
it means vagina the couples even get to
go on romantic dates like shane and
natalie's sailing adventure which gets
shane seasick i guess he had a little
too much late night snacks but it's here
we get one of shane's biggest red flags
he has an obsession with constantly
being showered in compliments do you
think do you think i'm pretty give you a
little more love than that there
why can't you brag about it you give me
the words of that man i like my ego goes
and when he does get a compliment he
lights up like a little school girl
you're like my number one why are you
smiling the couples also get to meet for
the first time making some awkward
situations and i don't just mean shake
handing his drink over to sal oh [ __ ]
and then yesterday she did like you got
to stop it it was bleeding
jarrett gets to meet malory the girl who
rejected him and shayna decides to leave
kyle but we aren't quite done with that
yet danielle doesn't attend because
she's busy recreating my college life
and it's here we also start to see some
of the cracks in the relationships you
joke a lot
i do i read it it kind of gets a little
old after a while
and also some cracks in the beach
furniture
[Music]
after being left in mexico kyle tries to
get some closure from shaina and to see
if there's still hope for their
relationship and one of the contentious
topics here was not spending the night
together spending the night together
yeah sharing a bag oh yeah and it was
moving way too fast meanwhile on the
first day in the ponds with shane i'm a
very sexual person so which i would
ideally like every day but the real
challenge for the couples comes when
they get back home are given their
devices back and must navigate the real
world while living together shayna gives
kyle a chance to meet her family and
it's a utter disaster are you a godly
man
[Music]
i don't know what that is i just don't
think kyle's the one for her
i would not be able to give shannon my
blessing i mean your mom is so sweet
now i get it why you're so sweet this is
pretty much the end of the line for kyle
and shayna their differences in faith
are too much in the to end the show here
well at least kyle does shayna will be
back and on the hunt for shane whose
relationship has been steadily growing
with natalie i can't stop like thinking
about change the couples also get to see
each other's apartments which leaves
much to criticize like jarrett still
holding on to gifts from his exes and
danielle's amazing hot dog costume but
hands down my favorite family goes to
danielle's whose mom wins the kathie lee
drunk wine mom award he's not as social
or quirky
i'm not saying that in a bad way sex
life is important she tends to
jeopardize her relationships
and danielle's brother gets right to the
hard-hitting questions asking ah so how
sexually active are you guys how are you
my son meanwhile more red flags pop up
for natalie about shane why what do you
listen to
like celine dion i don't really believe
in 401ks where i spend my money is on
food oh my god over like probably 2 000.
their relationship is really put to the
test when natalie surprises her
traditional korean parents that she's
getting married in two weeks and this
guy is her husband oh yeah baby
things go equally as well when natalie
meets shane's mom all right i'm gonna
take a number two i'll see you guys
later
seriously but trouble in paradise brews
for nick and danielle who have the
amazing ability to turn one small thing
into a fight of epic proportions did you
ever think the world doesn't revolve
around like you oh okay i had things
going on yesterday outside of your
meeting your family yeah you dummy this
homemade toothpaste isn't gonna make
itself for the most part the family
visits go well the contestants have to
field questions about if things are
moving too fast while some are open to
the experiment others can't and good
conscious give their blessing now if you
made it this far into the video it's
time for our mandatory animals of love
is blind montage
[Music]
with only 15 days left before the
weddings all the couples meet up for a
beach barbecue and drama is on the menu
shayna arrives having told natalie that
if things don't work out for her and
shane she knows someone she can hook her
up with it's a slap in the face and an
attack on a relationship that up until
this point is actually going pretty well
sheena wants shane and instead of being
an adult and expressing her feelings she
resorts to toxic tactics and
name-calling i feel like i'm being
portrayed as a certain like villain and
you guys relationship your guys's
[ __ ] fake ass relationship is such a
joke i'm sorry to hurt your feelings but
i'm again like i'm just being real if
you guys think you guys are compatible
that is comical if this is what the
people in heaven are gonna be like i
think i'll take my chances with kyle
jarrett introduces iana to his parents
but failed to mention anything about
love is blind of course they're going to
be in a shock when an entire camera crew
arrives i really love jared's dad he's a
minister just like my dad and he says it
would be an honor to do their ceremony
and just contrast the love and warmth
coming from his family to that of
shayna's deepti and shakes family
get-together goes equally as well with
shakes mom loving deepti so much she
turns on her own son and i do she
doesn't deserve someone who gives her
even half a percent less
and you know what she's absolutely right
we're all looking for that partner
that's gonna give us a hundred percent
and be there for us when we need them
the most but first wedding dress
shopping you know
no
we definitely know we don't like that
one it's all the more concerning when
you find out all these wine glasses on
the table are danielle's moms with just
a few days left before the wedding
shakes still caught up on deepti's
appearance and honestly at this point we
just need a counter we connect on so
many levels
except for the physical level but i
don't feel that kind of instinctual
physical attraction i don't really feel
that kind of animalistic attraction you
know i want to [ __ ] you emotionally
before i actually [ __ ] you
and it really begs the question can a
relationship work if you're not
physically invested in the other i guess
we'll see as we work our way to the
weddings but before we get there we have
the bachelor parties and what better
location for the men to celebrate than a
baseball field commonly associated with
curses shane who apparently has college
level baseball experience strikes out
more than me at the bar i'm piss [ __ ]
sal who's wearing dress shoes and tight
[ __ ] pants and can't swing a bad save
his life it's embarrassing as [ __ ] the
girls have their own tropical boat ride
along the chicago canals which recently
upgraded their water safety status from
toxic to very bad and damn is it ballsy
to have the bachelor and bachelorette
parties the day before the weddings do
we not remember the state jessica was in
last season i'm gonna go watch it here
dude
you and your dude and i know you
i know you baby i love you
if you were to ever to actively go after
my husband it's been awesome
the weddings are upon us and we have
five couples who have made the distance
but will we have five marriages and
prove that love is blind no way in hell
first up nick and danielle and there's
this look he makes coming down the aisle
which is just like woof he ends up
sweating more than jordan peel and that
one meme and in traditional love is
blind fashion they have those painfully
long pauses before our couples give
their answer nick and danielle end up
tying the knot and nick makes his way to
the nearest blow dryer to get rid of
whatever the hell this is and this next
up is deepti and shake and i gotta say
it was great to see this indian style
wedding on the show even if it was just
for the white guys trying to dance i
thought that shake was gonna say no here
but it's actually deepti who stands up
for herself and knows her worth i
deserve somebody who knows
for sure and she has a great line here
which i really loved and should be
indicative of any good relationship he's
not the one for me
because if he was he would make me feel
like i was the one and he never did that
shake actually takes it pretty well like
i can handle it
next is mallory and sal who in my
opinion had the least chemistry of all
the couples and i knew things were
getting off to a rocky start when the
ceremony begins with a mariachi ban but
if there was one person i expected to
say i do it was sal but he doesn't go
through with it and needs more time this
was a guy who busted out his ukulele
more than john mayer at a sorority party
so it really caught me off guard and
honestly i think mallory would have said
no too if things had gone any further
and now the couple shaina cursed with
the power of a thousand karen's natalie
and shane apparently the night before
the wedding and not caught on camera
they got in a huge fight a fight in
which shane was drunk who could have
thought this could happen having the
bachelor parties the night before but
just how bad this fight isn't revealed
until later natalie's dad is actually
the sweetest saying of all the things
i've done in my life
being your dad
my creator
and his greatest achievement is about to
dump a guy who wanted an old-fashioned
cocktail fountain at their wedding we
get an old-fashioned kind of like uh
fountain old-fashioned that just keeps
pouring out old-fashioned yes natalie
says no to shane i still love you and
you're still my best friend like
we have really big issues to sort
through and this was probably the best
decision especially after you get
emotional outbursts like this you think
that i'm actually gonna [ __ ] come
back to you after that kind of stuff
again apparently shane told her that he
hated her and she was the worst thing
that ever happened to him not really
what you want to be hearing the night
before your wedding my wealth gets me in
trouble
a lot but hey shayna guess who's
available the show ends on a happy note
however with jarrett eniana he even gets
those sneakers he promised he'd get her
for the reception something he mentioned
way back in the pods even though iana
still wants to see jarrett make some
adjustments she's ready to take the
plunge and the two get married leaving
this season with a two out of five
success but only time will tell if these
relationships will last in the words of
deep deep i guess love
isn't always mine now the end of the
show did say a new episode was coming
sometime in march but i'm not entirely
sure if this is one of those after the
season specials or the start of season
three love is blind did shoot two
back-to-back seasons so anything is
possible i hope you enjoyed my recap of
love is blind i have a bunch of other
fun videos in my worst shows playlist so
be sure to check that out and make sure
to like and subscribe thanks for
watching everyone for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
and until next time remember
you